pour ce fait des dizaines d'années que
je connaissais c'était mon confident une
personne et qui je faisais confiance les
yeux fermés
j'étais la femme de sa vie il blême
marié il me fait la grande demande même
devant son père
[Musique]
au début c'était très été merveilleux un
peu comme dans un conte de fées très un
homme très gentil et toujours prêt à
aider que tout le monde aimait à partir
du deuxième mois environ il ya commencé
le plus jaloux mais s'est enfermé entre
quatre murs que l'oeil devient quelqu'un
d'autre je prenais ma voiture en plein
hiver après les primes commission il
suivant un camion qu'une faisait des
rapides que je prenais j'ai une extase
si j'ai un téléphone cellulaire est
prête le moins évolué tous les jours il
va regarder à l'intérieur qui j'ai
appelé qui j'ai téléphonique 6g texter
poser des questions j'allais travailler
puis j'y revenais je voyais ça sent le
brûlé dans maison je me demandais
c'était quoi je reviens dans le bain
tout mes souvenirs d'enfance était
brûlée parce qu'il voulait projet de vie
j appartenais à lui il dit toujours que
je t'ai pobel que je valais rien que
j'étais super de qui regrettait d'être
avec moi j'ai un fils kaka beaucoup de
problèmes si étendue capistes à cause de
toi
si je me vient simplement comme
aujourd'hui qui est très simple mais
pour lui c'était trop osé jeter une cela
il y avait mis un micro dans ma voiture
il y avait des caméras la maison qui
pouvait voir de son cellulaire et d'une
autre petite télévision
j'étais constamment observer surveiller
contrôler leur dépendance à 3 15 minutes
même s'ils y arrivent au départ puis fin
de crise
ok si qui le castillo rien à faire là
dedans l'on se sort cause ma blonde
c'est ma femme fallait que je montre mes
mais mes relevés de paine mais pour voir
parce qu'il voulait calculer le nombre
d'heures que je travaillais pour voir si
je m'étais absenté si je le trompait les
crises de jalousie qu'on aime au début
viennent en grosses crises de jalousie
ça nous rend folle ou si on part
complètement confiance qu'on n'ose plus
prendre des décisions on n'ose plus on
n'ose plus avancé
[Musique]
quand je les laissais la première fois
le père a commencé au moment où je le
menaçait de partir de deux d'en parler à
ma mère vraiment que l'oeil perdait le
contrôle à la celle hawks a dégénéré
c'est un soir je voulais pas aller chez
eux judicaire non reprendre soir à lax
mais monsieur le propriété lui qui
décide c'est pour moi qu'elle doit
disais que je vais avoir un break
ben il ya des consignes qui a seulement
envoyé trois fois c'était ce soir là oui
il m'avait surpris en train d'expliquer
ma plus vieille que si jamais pape a été
violent avec maman ou qui arrivent et
quoi que ce soit je lui explique eca
devait aller cogner chez un voisin pour
demander de l'aide
le combat en temps du soleil est venu
pleut de rage il m'a poussé dans le meur
il ya pris ma fille il lancé contre le
mur dans sa chambre a fermé la porte
[Musique]
un soir j'ai dit guen c'était fini moi
je peux plus
vive la danoise était rendue je dormais
plus je faisais de l'insomnie j'avais
pas qui rentre chez moi il y au fond sur
moi mais prêt à gorge puis c'est le cas
comment samba mais pour comme les autres
fois va cette fois là je savais que je
m'en sortirais pas eu il m'a tellement
battu que deux ans après j'ai encore des
séquelles il dit je te le dis si tu t'en
veux je te tue j'ai dit kodjo un
stimulant je vais appeler la police
j'ai dit là tes menaces j'en peux plus
l'egypte heures mais j'ai dit non
j'ai appuyé sur le neuf pour faire le 9
à l'oeil ma m'a attrapé m'a jeté à terre
le mât traînée par les cheveux de
l'entrée jusque dans la cuisine des
coups de poing des jets en bon québécois
je mangeais la volée de may be il y
avait vraiment la main forte à gorge
puis de l'autre mais il battait depuis
des semaines sur le jeu n'en fais et
opère jeudi je vais passer cette nuit
mais je reviendrai jamais avec toi midi
par fed se sont joints entente dit
aujourd'hui son bord et est appelée
veulent chercher un verre d'eau avant de
mourir juste lui pas par quel miracle
mais ça a fonctionné
je suis parti à courir l'oeil maïmat vue
je pense que ça a frôlé y essayer de me
rattraper pour mieux rentrer dans la
maison
par chance il est pur réussi j'ai jamais
couru aussi vite que ça de toute ma vie
je me suis retrouvée dans la cage
d'escalier il y avait un homme qui était
logé hurler appelé la police appelé la
police si vous tuez vous êtes tués
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'avais le visage bleu javel sous la
gorge écrasé le nez cassé les ligaments
de l'oeil de chierry tomas qui a frappé
[Musique]
j'avais pour dire que j'ai mérité
donc j'ai mérité ses couleurs j'ai
mérité de me faire battre je méritais de
me faire frapper parce que c'est moi qui
l'a provoquée edit appel jamais la
police parce qu'il dit
il disait justement créé pas cette fois
là avec j'ai pas voulu porter plainte
mais si tu veux pas que j'agis comme ça
arrête d'un conte tromper arrête c'est
toi qui lis qui me rend agressif c'est
toi qui me qui me charge enviée et un
mausolée weitz et on sent que pam
on est isolé on sent mal qu'on est là
dedans on est tellement manipulé on est
tellement aveuglé
peu de données la paire l'allument il va
tout nous donner il était la plus belle
la plus firme il prenait soin de moi
vingt-quatre heures après ça ça
recommençait j'étais chez ma belle soeur
pour avoir une certaine sécurité puis
venus avec un cadeau aux phillies
cadeaux pour les enfants
je vais arrêter la drogue et tout va
bien à lyon je vais faire une thérapie
les paroles qu'on veut entendre le monde
y met et françoise malgré tout est en
vie je fais juste surveille dans la vie
je prends du hammam est complètement
mais un jour je vois ma vie comme avant
ça vaut la peine de se battre maintenant
ma vie est tellement belle
c'est incroyable je regrette pas du tout
m'a battue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]